so there is this particular C on our
planet Earth where even if you don't
know how to swim you will not sink this
body of sea water is called the Dead Sea
located in between Israel and Jordan and
why is it known as the dead zero well
because of its high salt and mineral
content very few bacteria and other
microorganisms are able to survive in
this body of sea water hence it is
called tent right that's where the name
Dead Sea comes from and because of its
high salt content we cannot sink because
of several times denser than ordinary
sea water very fascinating isn't it so
if you don't know how to swim and you
still want to float peacefully in the
sea you know where to go so comment down
below if you want to visit the Dead Sea
and if there are any more facts that you
want to share all right and subscribe to
our Channel